[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
reboot GameSpot's opinion editorial show
I'm Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker and
last week we put up a video that more
people seem to get mad about than our
previous episodes called video games
don't need to be fun a lot of comments
were either about it was just like we
predicted people saying yeah they do
or maybe I think there's a fair deal of
people that might not have watched all
the way through and we're kind of
wondering how we define fun when it was
one of the first things we did yeah it
definitely seemed like a lot of people
saw the title went in there and posted
in the comments some people did watch
the whole thing and some people did say
that it was poorly titled which I don't
entirely agree with but to an extent
yeah I think maybe we could have focused
it a little bit more maybe yeah I mean
there are a lot of people that liked it
but then said as a suggestion maybe pay
more attention to the titling and try
not to be too misleading which wasn't
our intent but if that was what came off
to enough people then we'll take that
into consideration in the future and we
appreciate the feedback maybe we could
have called it like video games can be
more than fun or something because yeah
a lot of people brought up like what we
defined as fun but we can get right into
the questions but yeah we appreciate
everyone's feedback and we'll keep that
in mind going into next week's episode
of reboot do you want to read the first
one sure uh Jed Barbour on YouTube who I
believe submitted a good question last
week maybe it's not the week before that
do you think we have limited ourselves
by using the term game it seems like the
term game implies fun but I don't think
the medium should only make fun
experiences it seems like the adherents
the idea that these are all games is
holding developers back for making these
truly deep experiences um I think the
traditional definition of videogame
could can be limited but this at this
episode is why we need to rethink that I
think I don't think games always have to
be fun
I think a lot of times they can just
actually be a good way to look at
something differently they could be a
respite from everyday routine they can
be you know a way to catch up with
people with friends that share the same
hobby which I mentioned the video but
you know we all play games for different
reasons but um yeah I mean I I don't I'm
not one of those people who thinks we
need to stop calling them video games I
think that's a fine name but I think we
do need to kind of let the definition of
video game kind of keep expanding which
I touched on yeah I I mean I I agree
with what you said I think that when I
think of game I do think of fun right
away like I'm gonna play a game I'm
gonna have some fun and I think that
there's a lot more to video games than
just having fun which is basically what
you just said well the next I'll read
the next one on youtubers because it's
pretty ties into this and Edie on
YouTube says if I'm not having fun on a
video game I stopped playing it period
video game should be fun or at least
mildly interesting hence the word game
so it sound like he had a similar
definition of the word game but again I
think that your game is kind of a dated
term that just that's what we call the
medium now and it's never going to
change and I don't want it to change
because I like the name video game but
yeah I think a lot of the games I played
this year were more for a horror
experience or something scary or
something negative that touched me in a
certain way and I I'll keep playing
games even if they're not always fun if
they do what they're trying to do
successfully and what they're trying to
convey to me then I'll keep playing them
yeah something that we didn't touch it
on the video that this kind of makes me
think of is a lot of times people don't
necessarily play games because they're
fun sometimes people play because
they're competitive sometimes we will
play them because I mean like a good
example is achievements and trophies
yeah right like people play those games
just for the satisfaction of unlocking
those trophies sure maybe that's fun to
some people but I feel like a lot of
people do it because they want to
collect or like Major League Gaming I
don't feel like a lot of the really good
pro gamers probably don't see like Call
of Duty or dota 2 or games like that as
fun anymore I mean I'm sure they still
at deep down really love the game just
like any like pro athlete but I still
think at a certain part at a certain
time is job and watching
pro-sports is fun but I think people who
watch like MLG stuff just get really the
nitty-gritty and the statistics and the
you know the spirit of the thing just
like people who watch basketball or
football or baseball but ya know every
the next one
sure phase LCP says this video is really
good and I agree with the idea I would
like to try some of the games that you
have talked about but you didn't put any
kind of list I can go be useful tool for
the viewers don't you think this one uh
kind of
not so much of a question directly
related to the episode but I thought it
might be good to talk about some games
that aren't necessarily fun in the
normal sense also infant if that would
help people if they want to know what
games we do touch on we could maybe in
the deck of the video put the thing I
was thinking too so thank you for the
feedback on that in terms of format
feedback on our videos and how we
present them that's always helpful just
like the titling this week and also yeah
if we if it's not directly related to a
game which our Zelda one obviously was
[Music]
resin Evil 7 obviously was but if it's
not if it's more of like a montage of
different games like this episode if it
helps people will definitely start
putting in like horizon night in the
woods outlast 2 yeah maybe the games we
reference to yeah but you were saying
you want to talk about yeah I mean I
don't know if there's a couple games off
the top of your head that you think that
aren't necessarily fun but you really
like to go back a little bit to last
year you had just mentioned Abzu did you
finish that I did finish Abzu and
absolute I loved but it's a game that I
have not wanted to go back to I've had
no desire to go back to yeah and I loved
my experience with it I thought it was
great but it wasn't fun in the sense
where I was trying to get through the
story or I was in like the mechanics the
mechanics are pretty good I was tricky
yeah it's weird
absolutely I've really liked I did not
have fun with it but I had all the
lights off my room it was kind of late
at night and it's about 3 MedicAlert
meditative yeah that's what's gonna say
it's very calming it was therapeutic for
me it's for those who don't haven't
played or haven't checked it out yet
you're a scuba diver kind of there's
also some more stuff that reveals itself
through in the ocean as you go through
and if you want you can literally sit on
these stones and meditate and zero in on
different wildlife and follow them
around
on fish or sharks or jellyfish or coral
or something I didn't do that as much
but I really like the game the controls
were great for underwater you know games
have this have a knack for making really
bad controls underwater and now I think
aside from prey zero-g is the new
underwater for games with bad controls
but it's a tangent I really like Abzu in
the sense that you know I played it it
calmed me down for about three hours
even when it kind of gets a little the
conflict gets introduced into the game I
thought I did a really good job walking
you through it at a kind of a snail's
pace but in a good way
yeah actually another one to that I just
thought of I actually thought the
gameplay mechanics everything were a lot
of fun in this game but I know a lot of
people felt that the Last of Us wasn't
that much I mean uh it's tricky right
more people if people thought it was too
overbearing yeah alright but people love
that experience anyway even though it
wasn't necessarily fun yeah I mean the
way they introduced certain characters
who will later die horrible deaths the
way that just the world itself is
oppressive from I mean the opening scene
is awful
yeah I won't spoil it I mean I'm sure a
lot of people have played it up you roll
up just you're gonna know right now I'm
not gonna spoil it but the main
character he dies right away no I'm just
kidding um you look like you Shou stole
that shirt from Topher Grace oh there
was there it is but that game is really
depressing and that's that game's
different the other one so much because
I do want to play The Last of Us again I
played it twice on ps4 since it came out
as the remaster edition
I can't wait for Last of Us to but yeah
that game kind of reminds me of like
alien one of my favorite movies i watch
it all the time but not because I'm
having fun doing it it's just oppressive
it's bleak there's a lot of daunting
things you get into and pretty sinister
people you meet but that game on the
mechanical foundation level I think is
fun to play yeah like I think it's very
well designed yeah in terms of that
sense but I can understand why people
wouldn't think it was fun but still feel
compelled to finish that game and last
game we could mention that Sherlock
vilifies journey I don't think it games
fun but I think it's pretty [ __ ]
powerful in a lot of ways yeah I think
it almost like what you described with
the Abzu very similar
uh this is Nico and he says this is on
YouTube by the way Nico he says great
video title can be misleading though we
kind of touched on this at the beginning
a little bit but yeah we we thought the
title was good we thought people would
be interested in it we knew some people
would take issue with it right but we
didn't think people would take that much
issue yeah it's worth us considering
moving forwards we don't want to
misrepresent me anything
people are saying was clickbait it's not
at all we were trying to do we were
trying to spark curiosity and maybe like
some conflict so when you get into it
you could see how we get to that point
which is the creative choice on our part
but if enough people said it enough
people watch it in like the video but
the title is misleading then we'll
definitely take them to account in the
future and we appreciate it we're gonna
call the next one what's better Xbox one
or ps4 ated butter on gamespot this is
an on-site comment this person said lol
this is exactly what I was telling
people in the comments for episode 5
about war the most important thing in a
game should be engagement games should
make you feel engaged and you can still
enjoy a game that doesn't feel fun and
doesn't need to make you feel happy or
excited some people will never never
understand this though and will forever
insist that this medium is a toy that
needs to entertain you a bit harshly put
but kind of what we were saying I don't
I don't I don't think people will
forever insist they probably they might
but yeah I think it's some people have
brought up games don't need to be fun
but they need to be entertainment and I
still kind of disagree with that yeah I
think this puts it pretty well in terms
of a engagement is important right like
there are some games they're not coming
too minor there that right now that are
meant to be not engaging in the sense
that like the controls are bad in a
certain way but Octodad yeah even even
gang B's to a certain extent but those
games are both fun the way that they use
those broken mechanics essentially you
know facilitate what's going on but yeah
I I love people are saying need to be
entertainment and I guess the bottom
line for this episode and feel free to
disagree with me is everybody looks at
games differently some people there are
people that don't even want to call them
games some people need engagement some
people need entertainment if you are one
of people that want to have fun with
games go for it that's much of the time
that's how I am but lately I've been
looking for more from
it's because games can do more games can
tell cooler stories and provide
experiences that no other medium can and
I love movies and I love reading all the
time but games provide something unique
and that's how the way I look at them I
guess cool so that's all the questions
we picked out for this week Jake went
through and sifted through them to find
those I'm sure you saw a lot of
criticisms in the thought process yeah
this is the hardest one to find
questions we always invite that
absolutely included some of these on
this episode but we always appreciate it
whether on YouTube or Twitter or case by
itself but it's about that time where we
talk about next week's episode Jake this
is actually your idea so I'll let you
hit the audience with this one yes so
we've been playing pray it is very
divisive
to say the least not between us yeah not
between us we actually both like it I
love the game I definitely have problems
with it but one thing I do really like
is side quests and how they are
entangled into the story and then how
they branch off and how they entangle
back in the story how they branch off I
think that is really cool and next
week's episode is going to be what makes
good side quests yeah and this is one of
those that sounds simple at first but
the more research I was doing I mean you
have to do much research I mean you can
look back at recent games like Witcher 3
did really great side quests uh yeah
pray you can look back at breath of the
wild they didn't really structure their
side quest but you keep coming across
them but then I look back at like the
earliest examples of side quests and I
get taken into like MMO side quests and
then when fetch quests started and when
fetch quests kind of died off recently
so this one as the other episodes will
be pretty deeply researched but yeah
it's kind of like gonna look at like
Jake said what makes a good side quest
tied into prey and knowing Jake will tie
it into the Witcher yeah and we will
have that up next week and as always in
the meantime keep hitting us up on
Twitter if you watch the video leave
some comments on youtube on gamespot if
you haven't watched previous episodes go
back and catch up we love if you can't
tell by these episodes we love having
audience talking to us and we really
appreciate your input your favorite part
of the show
and we're looking forward the next
episode see you then see you guys
[Music]
you